this one was pretty tricky for the first
one we get the HTML and send requests
for style dot CSS and timing J s so we
can rule out the inline option next we
get timing J s and execute it and CSS
arrives afterwards this tells me this
must be the async script because if it
weren't we'd have to block and wait for
CSS great job next one okay so we get
the HTML send request for style dot CSS
I don't see any requests for JavaScript
but then once we finish loading the CSS
we run the script so this must be the
inline case yep inline scripts block on
CSS and in this last one we have
requests for CSS and JavaScript and
JavaScript arise first but then we block
and wait until CSS is available so this
must be the blocking script tag